what's going on guys this is rob i just
got back from new york and i gave myself
a cold rahu so uh that sucks uh
literally i ordered mcdonald's for
breakfast like i'm having it ubered to
my house right i'm gonna spend all day
cleaning the house and playing star wars
fallen order or a jedi fallen order
because i've never played it before and
that's basically it but the cool thing
about being in new york is i got i got
pictures like these two one of the
things you guys may not know about me is
i'm a ridiculously talented photographer
little secrets little secrets so we are
covering a character today that i'm sure
most of you have never heard of i know i
never heard of him not even a lie to you
guys never heard of this guy once in my
life until this script was sent to me so
uh before we get into this guy's origins
of powers i'm going to just say up front
that this is not going to be like most
of the beyond omega level videos that we
do because this character is 100 meant
to be a comedic character so most of
what we talk about going forward in this
is just gonna be ridiculous but he is in
the main marvel universe so he's in
continuity and he is without a doubt
beyond omega level so edifice rex was
created by dwayne mcduffie and ernie
cullen and first appeared in damage
control number one in 1989 and if you're
not familiar damage control is a group
that most most of you probably never
even knew how to come a book run in the
first place but two is a company that
comes in and basically cleans up after
fights between superheroes and
supervillains or giant robots or
monsters or whatever causes property
damage that has to be controlled so
originally damage control was owned by
tony stark and the kingpin wilson fisk
but they eventually both sell their
stock and the companies bought by
another company and would eventually be
funded by shiel anyway rex randolph is
just a guy that works for damage control
and he's working on a cleanup job and he
finds a glowing green orb of course he
touches it which is what i would do what
most any of you guys would do just be
like what is this i'm gonna touch it
let's see what happens and upon doing so
he begins to transform now he remarks
that his cells are forming at incredible
speed causing his muscles to grow before
stating that his place is no longer on
earth and that his destiny lies
elsewhere and flies off to some unknown
destination now after that we don't
really see him again for two years there
are three more issues in the first
damage control mini series and rex isn't
even mentioned nor is he mentioned in
the four issue mini series that came out
later in 1989 and stretched into 1990.
it isn't until the third damage control
miniseries in 1991 that rex comes back
into the picture and by this time damage
control has found itself at the center
of some controversy because they start
showing up to jobs before any damage is
actually done so people begin getting
suspicious that maybe they're actually
causing destruction at these sites so
that they'll have something to clean up
and then make money now one of the
people who has this suspicion is robert
baldwin who is an intern at damage
control but who is also the superhero
known as speedball a member of the new
warriors which was a team that was
relatively new to marvel at the time and
was kind of like the young avengers
before the young avengers were a thing
i'm gonna be honest with you guys right
back in the day new warriors were legit
i don't care what anybody says like way
back in the day when the new warriors
first came around they were pretty solid
man so anyway speedball basically tells
the new warriors what he thinks is going
on with damage control and then tips
them off the damage control is going to
yankee stadium while the game is going
on now among those people in the
audience is the incredible hulk looking
absolutely ridiculous in a yankees hat
and talking to people about star trek
but right after the new warriors
confront damage control a glowing green
orb appears and transforms into rex
randolph who now goes by the nickname
edifice rex who informs them that he now
possesses powers of cosmic proportions
now he goes on to recount the day that
he came into contact with the green
globe which we still get no explanation
of in terms of what it was or where it
came from par for the course but we do
know that it made him incredibly
powerful and gave him a very specific
sort of cosmic awareness now rex has
decided to use his powers to achieve the
goals of damage control to clean repair
and restore and he calls himself
cosmically anal retentive which
basically just means that he is a neat
freak and likes to have everything in
order but the fact that he refers to
this ability as anal awareness is
admittedly pretty amazing i absolutely
love that but we immediately see that
rex has gained some sort of reality
warping or mana manipulation abilities
as he's able to level out a piece of
damage to earth by simply waving his
hand not only that but he's able to do
things like add starch to marvel boy's
cape and take away a kid's need to go to
the bathroom with a wave of his hand as
well so it does seem like he can alter
reality on a whim even though the way
he's doing it is just purposefully
absurd but when the new warriors realize
how powerful rex is they decide to
attack him genius level move there guys
no wonder civil war happened but he
basically thwarts their attack instantly
by encasing them all in double mylar
bags which if you're into collecting
comics is a popular way of preserving
books literally it's like he bored and
bagged the new warriors
those of you guys who don't know what
that means whenever you go to buy a
comic book they'll ask you do you want
to board like you want a board and back
depending on what store you go to
sometimes they'll just give you the
borden bag like a dick other times
they'll put it in they'll put the comic
in there for you uh sometimes they won't
do it because they don't want to take
the risk of damaging the comic but
literally you go to a comic book store
you see a comic book you see somebody
with one and it's got like a board in
the back in like a clear bag that's a
mylar bag right board and back so while
he's doing that rex basically gets the
idea to just tidy up the whole universe
all at once which draws the attention of
lord chaos the cosmic entity that is the
embodiment of chaos in the marvel
universe now lord chaos has a
counterpart in master order and the two
of them balance one another out but
rex's plan would of course throw that
balance off so lord chaos approaches
galactus and invites him to attend a
meeting of the cosmic entities who are
convening to decide what to do about rex
now galactus agrees to attend but
recruits the silver surfer to go to
earth and then retrieve the only people
who can stop edifice rex from carrying
out his plan the surfer agrees and goes
to earth where all of the heroes are
conveniently gathered to attend the
premiere of a movie about damage control
which nobody would ever do i mean damage
control was supposed to be a tv show and
as i understand maybe it was a tv show
maybe it wasn't i don't know i would
never have watched it because it sounds
terrible but he tells the heroes the
reason for his visit saying that the
universe is on the brink of destruction
now iron man attempts to answer his
question by assembling the avengers but
the server reveals that the only team
that can save the universe is damage
control so damage control goes with the
surfer into space and they arrive at a
meeting of the cosmic abstracts lord
chaos master order galactus death the
in-betweener oblivion and eternity i
mean the whole team's here of course
watching the watchers there because he's
there to watch which is literally all
he's good for so we know if all these
super powered entities are gathered to
talk about edifice rex and how to deal
with them this guy's a threat to the
whole universe so we're already way
beyond omega level just right here but
during the meeting rex displays his
power once more by giving infinity a
manicure which while this is once again
meant comedically he alters the
appearance of a cosmic abstract just
take that in for a second this guy
changes the way a cosmic entity looks
even incontinuity the only being out
there who's been able to physically
change the way a character looks just on
a whim by altering them was in the old
fantastic four stories not really the
old ones but the moderately old
fantastic four stories when the
fantastic four met god and he fixed the
scar on reed richard's face i think it
was the only time we've ever really seen
that happen in this way right so you
could make a legitimate argument this
guy's power is on the level of god but
regardless this guy has a great deal of
power so the cosmic council then
questions rex as to what he intends to
do with his power and he tells them that
because everything got so messy after
the big bang that he's gonna put things
back to how they were prior to the big
bang meaning he's gonna put everything
back into a cosmic egg like it was
before it exploded rex then returns to
earth and when asked by damage control
why they don't stop him they straight up
admit that they can't
literally the cosmic entities are like
because we can't
there's nothing we can do here right
like they literally say that engaging in
battle with rex would result in grave
damage to them and upset the balance of
the universe now the silver surfer
brings damage control back to earth
where all the heroes the avengers the
x-men fantasy for the warriors they've
all gathered to mount one last stand
against edifice rex who i forgot to
mention has enlarged his own size that
he's the same height as galactus by this
point but before the battle breaks out
the guy in charge of damage control a
dude named john porter simply fires rex
that's it like he literally just says
you're fired and rex shrieks back to
normal size and heads for the
unemployment line and the threat is
neutralized i mean yeah don't get me
wrong there's nothing serious about this
and it's absolutely ridiculous right
it's a ridiculous ending to a pretty
ridiculous story and we've never seen or
heard from edifice rex again to my
knowledge so yeah i mean the stuff this
guy did was just crazy is the story
meant to be taken seriously no right and
if you get pissed off because of how
this story was like if you're like
that's a ridiculous ending yeah i know
it's supposed to be so with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end
thank you all for watching and dealing
with my nasally voice and i will catch
you all later
peace